unos investigadores calificaron 31
atletas en una prueba de agilidad aquí
están sus resultados y tenemos este
histograma lo que voy a preguntarte es
cuál de estos intervalos a b o c
contiene la mediana de los resultados y
cuál de estos intervalos o dame una
estimación de cuál contiene la media de
los resultados pagos el vídeo e intenta
responder la pregunta
bien empecemos con la mediana podemos
pensar a la mediana como el número de
enmedio o si tienes un número par de
datos será el promedio de los dos puntos
de enmedio en este caso tenemos un
número impar de datos así que será el
punto de en medio cuál será el punto del
medio si ordenamos de menor a mayor
bueno será que el que tenga 15 de cada
lado por lo tanto será el decimosexto
dato dejan notar lo así que pensaremos
acerca de cuál de estos intervalos
contienen ese decimosexto dato y bueno
puedes pensarlo como el decimosexto
empezando por el mayor o por el menor ya
que es el de en medio entonces empecemos
por los mayores ok
ese intervalo se contiene los primeros
trece puntos mayores y el intervalo b va
del décimo cuarto punto mayor hasta el
décimo octavo punto mayor así que este
intervalo p
es el que contiene la mediana contiene
el decimosexto punto mayor o si
empezamos de la izquierda también será
el décimo sexto punto más bajo y
llegaremos justo al mismo intervalo al
intervalo b y aquí es donde están la
mediana ahora cuál es la estimación para
la media bueno ya hemos calculado la
media anteriormente pero cuando ves una
distribución como esta cuando observas
el histograma como puedes pensar acerca
de la media será el punto de balance si
piensas que este histograma está hecho
de un cierto material de no ser digamos
una densidad uniforme donde pondríamos
un pulcro o un pivote para equilibrar lo
bueno observa si ponemos el fulcro por
aquí parece que se inclinaría a la
izquierda porque esta es una
distribución asimétrica a la izquierda
es decir tienes una larga cola a la
izquierda
si realmente quisiéramos balancearlo
tendríamos que poner el fulcro como por
aquí un poco más hacia la izquierda es
decir en dirección a la cola yo estimo
que esto quedaría balanceado si ponemos
el fulcro más cercano al intervalo a el
cual va a ser el intervalo que contenga
la media la intención de este tipo de
ejercicios no es que calcules con cada
punto los sumes todos y los divididas
entre 31 de hecho no nos dan toda la
información aquí el punto es que hagas
una estimación y de que obtengas la
intuición de que si tienes una
distribución asimétrica hacia la
izquierda como están a menudo te
encontrarás con la situación donde tu
media está a la izquierda de tu mediana
como aquí observa si tuvieras una
distribución asimétrica hacia la derecha
tendrías el caso contrario y como
veremos cuando tengas una distribución
simétrica o aproximadamente simétrica la
mediana y la media estarían muy cerca
entre ellas de hecho si tuvieras unas
perfectamente simétrica entonces la
media y la mediana podrían ser la misma
podrían estar en el mismo lugar perfecto
hagamos otro ejemplo nos dicen aquí
tenemos las edades de 14 compañeros de
trabajo y quiero que me digas
aproximadamente donde está la media y
dónde está en la mediana estará
aproximadamente en am
ence pausa el vídeo e inténtalo primero
empecemos con la mediana déjame notarlo
tenemos 14 edades o 14 datos por lo
tanto tendremos el promedio entre los
dos puntos de enmedio es decir el
promedio entre el séptimo y el octavo
dato y bueno podremos decir 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 aquí tenemos el séptimo y el octavo
está por acá por lo tanto el séptimo
está en el intervalo de 30 años y el
octavo está en el intervalo de 31 años
entonces el promedio de estos dos nos
llevará a b
aquí tenemos a la mediana otra forma de
pensarlo es darnos cuenta a simple vista
que tenemos la misma cantidad de puntos
por abajo de bem que los que tenemos por
arriba de v lo que nos da un buen
indicador de que la mediana está en b y
que hay de la media bueno tenemos una
distribución perfectamente simétrica
si quisiera balancear la pondría el
fulcro justo aquí en medio por lo tanto
puedo decir con certeza que la media
también estará en b y ya con esto hemos
acabado nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo